all right thousands of people in Central
Michigan are out of their homes because
of historic flooding homes were left
submerged after a pair of dams failed
near the city of Midland Michigan
Governor Gretchen Whitmer says it's
being called a 500 year event 10,000
people were ordered to evacuate
floodwaters ripped apart roads after
breaking through those dams which are
nearly 100 years old now the river they
requested at a record 35 feet and is not
expected to recede under flood stage
until Sunday I know Anthony you look at
these pictures and we're waiting to talk
to the governor we're dialing her up but
you look at these pictures and you have
to say this is the last thing they need
at this particular time you know it's
gone from stay-at-home orders to
evacuation orders as you said 10,000
people have been asked to leave their
homes and it's just everywhere you look
it's it's a crisis in the state of
Michigan right now when you're looking
at these pictures you know it was
interesting in in Janet shamlian --zz
report earlier in our broadcast she was
talking to a woman who lived there and
she said how does it feel with this
coming on the heels of of the corona
virus and she said you know we were just
going through this you know we were just
learning to what we really appreciated
in life because of what we've been
through and and now we're dealing with
this gale yes I heard her say that I've
resonated with me - we're joined now by
mission go Michigan Governor that's
Gretchen Whitmer she's in the governor's
mansion in Lake Lansing and this is her
first interview since this flooding
disaster began governor first let's say
it's good to see you we're glad we got
you up but this these pictures are
heartbreaking this is the last thing
your state needs at this particular time
it's like a crisis within a crisis I
know you did an aerial tour what's your
assessment of the damage well that's
right Gail and I think that it's really
important to note on Tuesday we were
trying to evacuate about 10:00
thousand people and social distance and
as you can imagine incredibly stressful
circumstances but as I surveyed the
damage yesterday from the air there's no
question it was the right thing to do
and because the people of Midland took
this so seriously
we haven't reported any casualties and
that's pretty amazing but in looking at
it you can see houses that have water up
to the roofline you can see a lake that
was drained out there's no lake there
anymore because it's all at the lower
end of the river no and so just trying
to keep people safe
we've got shelters that are functioning
the water should start to receive now
but there's no question that this is a
devastating event I'm glad to hear
governor that there was no loss of life
it's hard to believe when you look at
the pictures it's being reported that
one of those dams was labeled a high
hazard a couple of years ago I realized
that you were not governor at that time
but why do you think that that was not
corrected and what action are you
planning to take now well there's no
question that across our country we've
not been investing in infrastructure
this was an old dam this was a dam that
we are currently in legal wranglings
with the owner of it and so the lack of
investment it has has come to show that
these fundamental infrastructure things
are important and that's why as I Ronen
as a governor have been trying to get my
legislature to join me and make it
investments in everything from fixing
the dam roads which is what I ran on to
rebuilding our infrastructure which
includes dams across our state and
bridges with a number of bridges that
were wiped out yesterday because of the
water as well and so as a nation this is
something that is not unique to Michigan
but the pain right now certainly is and
that's why we're going to do everything
we can to get responsible parties to be
held accountable and to ensure that
we're helping these homeowners and and
the people that have been displaced get
back on their feet well you know the gut
you know the President Trump is heading
to your state today are you hoping or
planning to meet with him to discuss how
the federal government can help you
during this time
we do not have plans to meet but I did
speak with him yesterday on the phone I
made the case that you know we all have
to be on the same page here we have stop
demonizing one another and really focus
on the fact that the common enemy is the
virus and now it's a national disaster
this is what all of our focus should be
on I'm grateful for the fact that FEMA
has been such a great partner and and
that's what my message to him was let's
let's try to focus on the true enemy
which is the virus and and this natural
disaster and and let's try to put
everyone who has a platform on the same
page of saying let's do this and let's
keep people safe in the process that's
always been my call and that was what we
talked about a little bit yesterday as
well well the president made it very
clear governor that he's upset with your
state he called you said your Secretary
of State had gone rogue had mailed out
absentee ballots it turns out it's
absentee ballot applications and he
threatened to withhold federal funding
he seems to have walked that back a
little bit but what do you what is your
response to that well you can only
imagine how I feel about that you know
we are in the midst of this global
pandemic we've lost 5,000 people in the
state of Michigan it's been devastating
we are at a point where we think it's
safe to start reengage in sectors of our
economy but then this blood hits and
we've got it evacuate tens of thousands
of people who are worried and scared on
top of this global pandemic and to have
this kind of distraction is just
ridiculous to be honest it's the
threatening to take money away from a
state that is hurting as bad as we are
right now is just scary and I think it's
something that is unacceptable and my
hope is that today he will be in
Michigan he will see we are hard-working
good Americans we need the support of
our federal government as much as
anybody else if not more right now
because of this added challenge and that
I'm hopeful that he comes away knowing
that that's what's most important no
petty political stuff that he
going with the Secretary of State
yesterday we've got to be focused on
doing the right thing right now on
behalf of the people there certainly
seems to be a lot of challenges in
Michigan you know you yourself are
getting pushback from many of your
constituents who say listen we need to
get back to work
they've been protesting they've been
very loud they've been very angry
President Trump seems to be encouraging
the state to reopen what is your message
to the protesters well yesterday you
know I just juxtaposed the fact that I
was standing in Midland talking to the
press talking to the people people were
so grateful that you know we showed up
we've seen volunteers come out I mean
what the community reaction has been
we're all in this together let's pull
together and take care of one another at
the same time in Lansing in seven people
cutting here and a couple of hundred
show up to protest and and with all
their protest propaganda the fact of the
matter is the vast majority of people in
Michigan and this is true in every state
I'm confident understand how serious
this moment is and are willing to do the
right thing we have made incredible
sacrifice we can't let that have been
made in vain and just drop our guard and
go back to life as normal life is going
to be different for a while let's be
smart
let's reengage and let's avoid a second
wave because that would be more
devastating than what we've been through
you know it's gonna be a new normal for
all of us governor we've got to go but
you know you're on the short list it's
been reported you're on the short list
for Joe Biden's VP candidate are you
interested in the position I know you
got a lot to do right now but are you
interested in the position I have my
hands full in Michigan it's an honor to
be included among this incredible group
of leaders that they're talking to and
I'm not gonna say more than that all
right
all right very diplomatic answer we
Thank You governor Whitmer we thank you
for taking the time we really appreciate
it